foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is
scp-7140 containment class ketter
secondary class Abaddon disruption class
Amita and risk class critical
does the black moon howl
I was in remorse when the song it sings
ends the world
special containment procedures
the SCP Foundation United Nations Global
occult Coalition Republic of India
Federal Democratic Republic of Nepal and
People's Republic of China have signed
the Treaty of Everest to establish
indefinite and reliable containment of
scp-7140 it stipulates the following
initiatives to be carried out to address
the object
number one every year from the 1st to
the 8th of July the foundation is to
work with all members of the treaty to
entirely prohibit entry into the
Himalayan Mountains a suitable cover
story pertaining to the prevalence of
deadly Avalanches at that time is to be
created and disseminated by the
aforementioned parties
number two an annually assembled Joint
Task Force jtf Theta Mendes 1740 7th
spear composed of at least 1 000
available troops sourced from combat
capable mobile task forces and at least
2 000 troops sourced from the physics
division of the GOC is to be stationed
at the base of the Himalayas for the 192
hours during which the above protocol is
active during this time all members of
group of Interest Alpha 19 Serpent's
hand and group of Interest 231 Children
of the Scarlet King detected by Theta
Mendes 7140 within their area of
occupation are to represent security
breaches of the highest priority and be
terminated on site
description
scp-7140 is a seven day long ritual
performance of Russian composer
Alexander scribins mysterium though a
famously unfinished composition
according to mainstream belief the
complete composition of
scp-7140 achieves its complete length by
a repetitive application of
compositional elements from the publicly
known mysterian piece throughout them
extensively integrating other artistic
religions and ritual demonstrations that
cannot be definitively located as
belonging to any singular historical
Source the mysterium has been described
as a synesthetic piece able to induce a
multi-sensory experience by use of music
and also inducing visual performances
alongside thomatological ritual elements
esoteric spiritual and philosophical
view similar to theosophy is known to
have influenced its compositions a link
between these esoteric beliefs and the
ritual nature of scp-7140 is exceedingly
likely extensive thermaturgic working
and collusion with pluripotent or
theological entities to Aid in the
process of scp-7140s composition would
likely have been necessary to achieve
its degree of potency
scp-7140's anomalous ability derives
from Human artistic and Theological
conceptual attribution within the NOAA
sphere and is therefore Reliant upon
several Concepts invented and imagined
by humankind as such the finished
mysterium composition has been
designated a dormant blavonsky class
hypersigil of type 9 eschatological
severity by the research head for
scp-7140 with the approval of the chairs
of foundation Departments of Applied
esotericism psychology and
parapsychology and mimetics and counter
mimetics
[Music]
chronological events and effects of
scp-7140 originates from the doomed
alternate universe Hereafter classified
as Au 7140 UK as per statement 3.1 of
the 1981 multifoundation Coalition
agreement and inter-universal Concord
that ensures all documents containing
information relevant to an irreparable
k-class scenario in any given alternate
foundation's universe be autonomously
transmitted to all other Coalition
members for cautionary and informative
purposes
secure the past contain the present
protect the future
to be properly executed
scp-7140 is to be initiated and
completed at the base of the Himalayan
Mountains beginning on the 7th of July
the beginning of the performance
produces an immensely powerful class
Delta telepathic signal contacting all
sentient and non-sentient life on Earth
and compelling them in what has been
described as a spiritual or religious
experience to make an immediate
pilgrimage to the site at which
scp-7140 is being performed
non-sabian life forms including even
those without rudimentary external
awareness such as plants or fungi assume
an unknown elevated State of
Consciousness as to obtain sapience and
be affected by scp-7140's compulsion
entities occupying any Earth adjacent
metaspatial dimensionality within a 5.4
human variance range of Baseline reality
are also compelled by
scp-7140 and will make all attempts
possible to exit their current Dimension
and reach the sign of scp-7140 on Earth
during performing of the anomaly
scp-7140 allegedly induces a distinct
Astro corporealization in those who
witness it a common theory among the
foundation of au 7140uk being that the
piece overstimulates every sensory mode
of human perception to the point of
forcing one's Spirit out of the body
through astral projection execution of
the entire Pace involves among other
elements dances A procession the burning
of incense Mass distribution of
psychedelic substances displays of
multicolored light by use of a system of
reflective prisms and a variety of
illusions
of the performance itself scriabin wrote
there will be not a single spectator all
will be participants the work requires
special people special artists and a
completely new culture the cast of
performers includes an orchestra a large
mixed choir an instrument with visual
effects dancers A procession incense and
rhythmic textual articulation the
cathedral in which it will take place
will not be one single type of stone but
will continually change with the
atmosphere and motion of the mysterium
this will be done with the aid of mist
and Light which will modify the
architectural Contours
if
scp-7140 remains uninterrupted for the
entirety of its execution its impact
upon local land existential reality will
continually increase in severity as
documented by its SCP Foundation events
in AU 7140uk caused by the continued
performance of scp-7140 progressed in
the following order when it was
performed
note that this timeline pertains to the
context of au 7140 UK and would likely
not transpire in an identical manner
where
scp-7140 to be initiated in the prime
timeline
time from initiation of
scp-7140 10 minutes
event
all conscious life forms on Earth and
adjacent dimensions are simultaneously
made aware of the existence and location
of the scp-7140 ritual within the
unconscious mind despite cognitive
difficulties and consciously associating
this Revelation with a literal event at
first affected entities unfailingly
conclude that they must make a
pilgrimage to the site of scp-1740
within minutes of this effect's initial
onset almost certainly initiating a BK
class broken masquerade scenario
time from initiation of scp-7140
approximately 30 minutes
event
Hume level of Earth and the surrounding
area within a radius of approximately
0.67 light years begins to steadily
climb throughout the duration of
scp-7140 reaching a climax of around 500
percent in excess of normal levels
time from initiation of scp-7140 24
hours
event
manifestations of extra dimensional
phenomena within Baseline reality reach
unprecedented length frequency and
clarity
time from initiation of scp-7140 32
hours
event
ambient decaiva radiation present on all
achiva sensitive areas or holy sites on
the planet rapidly increases to on
natural levels over the course of around
6 hours starting at this time before
abruptly shooting downwards to near zero
for the duration of scp-7140 over the
coming days anomalous phenomena destroys
several of these sites by Apparent
overwhelming Force Major the noospheric
and physical influence of theological
meme plexes worshiped by Humanity
weakens continuously as this process
continues
time from initiation of scp-7140 65
hours
event
beginning at this time numerous
unprecedented geographical changes occur
within a short amount of time most of
them occurring within 48 hours or less
the sudden rising of most of the
zealandian continental crust to above
sea level at approximately 68 hours
displaces an immense amount of water in
the oceans as does the sudden emergence
of two large landmasses shortly
thereafter one in the mid-pacific ocean
at around 75 hours and one in the Arctic
Ocean near the North Pole at around 81
hours starting at this time and until
the conclusion of scp-7140 several new
islands emerged from under the sea some
existing ones sink or are destroyed and
the position of several existing islands
and continents is shifted overall for
the duration of these events significant
natural disasters including volcanic and
tectonic activity flooding and tsunamis
severely impact almost all islands and
low lying coastal areas on the planet
time from initiation of scp-7140 70
hours
event
a remarkably destructive series of
volcanic eruptions causes a blanket of
Ash to block sunlight from reaching the
Earth
time from initiation of scp-7140 90
hours
event
several operatives of group of Interest
231 Children of the Scarlet King
vanished through unknown means anomalous
spatial and or metaspatial displacement
is likely
time from initiation of scp-7140 120
hours
event
through unknown means scp-140 achieves
full chronological completion and
breaches into the present moment
time from initiation of scp-7140 144
hours
event
scp-001 l-i-l-y is triggered initiating
an event known as the final day of
flowers
time frame initiation of scp-7140 150
hours
event according to on-site artificial
intelligence conscript records an
estimated 90 percent of contained
Sapient and sentient anomalies have
breached containment in an attempt to
reach the site of scp-7140
time from initiation of scp-7140 157
hours
event
the human NOAA sphere and the regions of
physical space-time to which it is
associated namely all human-inhabited
regions on the planet cease to exist
individually
fully merging into a composite pocket
dimension in which the gap between
Consciousness and matter is fully
reconciled and the cognatron can
directly interact with physical
particles before first undergoing
cyogenesis
time from initiation of scp-7140 168
hours
event
the eschaton occurs in full triggering a
UK Class end of universe scenario
addendum 7140 1. discovery
the existence of
scp-7140 first came to the attention of
the foundation following the 1962
Alexandria incident references to it
being noted among the immense collection
of esoteric scripture that was brought
back to reliquary area 27 when the
incidents after math necessitated the
immediate evacuation of all SCP
Personnel out of The Wanderers Library
among the recovered texts are several
grimois written in the old devite
language which contain instructions on
performing
scp-7140 and the consequences thereof
said texts cannot be identified as
originating from any definite point in
time and possess multiple incongruent
temporal signatures from greatly
disparate eras notably appearing to be
at least 800 years old upon physical
analysis yet directly citing the
mysterium itself supposedly left
unfinished upon scrabin's death in 1915
a clear anachronism
a Common Thread between most texts
recovered from the 1962 Alexandria
incident particularly those which
reference
scp-7140 is a frequent Association of
scp-001 tufto and Associated Divine
entities with apocryphal eschatological
infernal and otherwise Fringe abrahamic
symbolism particularly those abrahamic
symbols with connections to the biblical
Revelation or end times
many later occult texts with mentions of
scp-001 tufto that are known to
originate from The Wanderers Library
such as those obtained from the global
occult Coalition following their raids
on the Serpent's hand seem concurrent
with the Alexandria incident texts and
their portrayals of the Scarlet king and
the symbols of its worship this evidence
seems to strongly suggest that the ways
in which the library specifically
portrays scp-001 tufto are somehow
unique and further implies an unknown
connection between the Serpent's hand
and the children of the Scarlet King
following Discovery by the foundation
containment protocols within the
Himalayan area were temporarily imposed
while additional research could be
conducted though this research proved
relatively unfruitful the dissemination
of documents from Au 7140 UK in 1994
enlightened the foundation to the truth
of scp-7140's existence and its true
dangers shortly after a treaty to
establish intensified defense measures
in the area was ratified this agreement
the Treaty of Everest remains in use to
this day and has thus far proven
effective in disarming any third-party
attempts to initiate scp-7140
addendum 7140 2. recovered documents
the following incomplete set of
recovered texts understood to be written
by scriobin himself detailed the precise
mechanics of scp-7140 and the
circumstances of its Creation with
reasonable accuracy the documents are
written in a mix of Russian ancient
Greek and Nokian Atlantean and old David
and encountered by the use of a complex
cryptomatic Cipher that has yet to be
fully cracked despite years of
collaborative effort between the
foundation and the international center
for the study of unified thematology on
breaking this thomaturgic Cipher the
following transcription is not currently
fully translated completely untranslated
phrases will be expunged and words are
phrases with more unreliable
translations will be marked with an
asterisk for clarity
2nd of November 1903.
magic is a thing of innumerable swelling
thoughts dreams and probabilities but
for all its Cosmic impossibilities and
inconsistencies magic is also a thing of
the Fates
it is inevitable
it was a thing of the Fates that
compelled my soul to a new aim a final
and magnificent expression of rebirth an
exaltation of the immortal Spirits
divinely inspired Myriad Arcane
awarenesses and ecstasies
my final piece will be one of these as
they have inspired me
the secret Doctrine teaches that
throughout the entire duration of
intelligent life in our world a clear
chronology of major civilizations can be
drawn each emerging after the previous
and each acting is a major event of
change upon the world in time immemorial
the
instated themselves as the first such
civilization
eternus installed Humanity as the sixth
when building their first great City and
though they fell Humanity again proved
their worth re-emerging after extensive
competition with the children of the
night and stars jeopardized the
legitimacy of our claim to the title of
sixth great civilization the seven
extensively predicted but never
identified is forthcoming the ancient
Masters lie this information out for us
in its totality their wisdom is Paragon
and undeniable and it is formed by their
teachings that I believe the seventh
realm of our world as it is called is
imminent
I wish to welcome my own fate and the
fate of the world and to end our time in
this realm with celebration should
mankind be predestined to cede our
dominion over this world to a more
advanced species my next piece will be a
recognition of humankind in the grand
face of the infinite Cosmos to be played
preceding its inevitable end
19th of May 1905.
the work I have done for my latest
project is of truly Arcane nature and it
has humbled me with a newfound Majesty
for the grand harmonic Confluence of
probabilities that make the realm of
magic in which we exist possible
our standing in the cosmos is but one
level in an infinite structure of
countless rising and falling planes of
existence octave over Octave of rock
Tafe the planes Ascend further still
it is truly amazing
yesterday during hours spent reading at
the Russian State library in Moscow a
faceless cloaked figure with four arms
four vaguely arachnoid legs and no
manner of Arcane symbols painted upon
its reptilian flash emerged suddenly
from in between the bookshelves in a
manner I can only describe as a
hallucination it approached me and
placed my hands in a large green and
gold leather-bound Tome with the symbol
of the world tree cast upon its cover in
bras at first frightened it might
demeanor quickly changed to utter
astonishment when I realized that the
Tome was tangible to me and the
experience that I had been almost sure
was illusory was indeed entirely real
the mysterious creature surely some
angel of wisdom to bestow me with the
text and its vast knowledge then
promptly melded back into the
surrounding environment
and vanished
I have thought for many days about what
occurred at that Library coming to only
one conclusion it appears that the
Universe Has Smiled upon my work and
showed me its wisdom
what's serendipity
the tone which I have obtained is itself
extraordinary it teaches me a far-flung
civilizations Across the Universe and of
their customs and traditions it teaches
me the intricacies of ancient rights
lost to time everywhere else but in its
very content it teaches me of the long
forgotten history of our own world and
of the varied ways in which the
essential Breath of Life expresses
itself and creates intelligence
its teachings will surely be
instrumental in designing the rights
necessary for my peace
the 23rd of October 1908.
years of work on my final project have
thus far continued smoothly all great
wonders and Horrors which I learn of
throughout my continuous study will be
integrated and invoked in the
performance and aged spirit and deity
recognized and thanked for its role in
our realm's mortal experience
the term bestowed upon me by the in 1905
has since taught me the intricacies of
the library
the realm of infinity Knowledge from
which it presumably originates
I have also since translated the true
name of the text the sixth term of
apocryphal Visions one of many texts
within the library containing similar
wisdom
I sometimes experience visions of the
library in its winding halls I see
creatures nearly identical to the angel
which handed me the sixth term
I have designed rituals to invoke the
Heavenly spheres for their blessing upon
the coming age and ritual I have
communed with each planet and star in
the night sky with each's logos with
ages peoples though in all that the
spiritual Masters have told me one
particular Motif stands out
the Realms say to me it would seem that
great power comes from entities and
domains on the furthest frontiers of
existence the voids between and Beyond
universes or any other Cosmic Locale in
which man has never set foot
the Gods in these far away places give
the greatest rewards of power to those
able to find them
when the end comes I will accept the
Infinity of Fate with open arms and make
humankind's dissolution into the calm
finality of ultimate Annihilation as
painless as possible
I will contact this mysterious force and
use its power to compose the ultimate
spell
[Music]
6th of July 1910.
I have recently made contact with a
mysterious and Elusive entity which I
believe to be the force which I've been
attempting to locate
it's Dominion which it often shows to me
in my dreams and Visions is the Serene
void positioned between the Quantified
realm of structured and audit Concepts
and the infinity chaos of primordial
unknowns when I'm taken there I can feel
the minuscule interactions and one's
body usually makes with surrounding air
and dust give way to the numbness of an
absolute vacuum
I have been led to the knowledge of this
entity's existence by way of the
library's Tome but it contains no
further information concerning this
mother if I am the first to reach this
strange realm this point in my mission
may be as far as the Tome is able to
take me
entities which occupy the void realm are
utterly foreign to my understanding but
do not appear to be hostile towards me
I've become more and more convinced that
it is only with the aid of these beings
that the rights and rituals I can pose
will have their power for it is in
balance that all magic is found will
continue to attempt to negotiation for
the good of all I will unwaveringly
continue in the development of my
ultimate working
9th of August 1914.
Faust once made a deal with the devil in
exchange for his Immortal Soul Faust
detained all worldly knowledge and
ability which could possibly Be Imagined
Faust would become the most talented
Magician of his time and in the most
talented Alchemist of his time and
Fortune would always look upon Him
favorably in the world of men but none
of this mattered for in the kingdom of
God Faust was utterly corrupted his soul
always belonged truly to Lucifer
I too unbeknownst to myself have fallen
victim to such a bargain
The Whispers with whom I made a covenant
to create my final work on not who they
claimed to be I've discovered but indeed
only Servants of the Crimson Beast
kaharak Lord of Darkness below god of
the Deva a treacherous and brutal
Scourge existing only to devour and
defile all things holy his is a raging
spiraling insatiable typhoon of primeval
wrath gluttony dust blood and Corruption
the king revealed his true nature to me
only after he agreed to my terms for the
use of the void's power in my workings
he has defiled all that was once sacred
and divine in my magnum opus destroying
years of work years of Dreams he has
defiled and perverted the Magics of my
intricate composition transforming it
into an aberrant tool of Destruction it
appears that his influence has turned my
work once dedicated to easing the pain
of a Dying Humanity into the very thing
that will destroy it
despite all this tragedy it is far too
late for me to stop Fate has already
dealt her hand that of annihilation and
as such
I am Resolute in accepting it regardless
of the innumerable and ungodly Terrors
which the fruits of my pride may be
doomed to inflict it is fated that the
work will be completed and as such I
must complete it regardless of the cost
Faust once stood at the gates of hell in
infamy all at one moment
the weight of his guilt crushed him
starting in early to mid-april 1915
until his death scrayabin was rendered
bedridden due to an infected sore
as his writing from this period is
featured below note that according to
scrabin's doctor he exhibited signs of
deliriousness during this time
of immeasurable swirling tensions
impulses and Misfortune but for all his
Cosmic impossibilities and
inconsistencies kaharic is also a thing
of the Fates
is inevitable
time and time again the king makes
himself visible in my dreams at times of
fear delusion and delirium he brings
with him in his wake all the infinite
terrors in his damning void Realm
and all Cosmic cataclysms inflicted by
his terrible Legions of scourges and
devourers
the realm of the sixth is fated to fall
and in his ashes the realm of the
seventh must rise
if this transition occurs only through
him there is no imaginable impossibility
which may protect us from it this too
will be an act of the fate and it is my
duty to complete my work regardless of
its cost
as the life Fades from my own body I
feel more and more the impending onset
or new age of Life everywhere on Earth
just some hundred odd years from when I
write
a promised land so Within Reach and yet
so far from realization
if the gods of fate and Fortune shine
their light upon us before the king
butches them whole the end of the human
race will not be met with apocalypse but
with a clean slate
and a new beginning
would pass away seven days later on 14th
of April 1915 in his Moscow apartment
due to severe complications from the
infected sore on his upper lip
okay
I think that about does it for today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
Rowan O'Brien
braided Peach
Dean dengus
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
sagnar
your local Foundation agent
Lost Boy
and jam Saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you